i
All right. Wonderful.
Cindy Padnos, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
It's a pleasure to be here. Thank you.
It's so great to have you.
I can't wait to learn so much
as much as I can
over these next 20 minutes.
You know, I'm not gonna be able to do justice
for all the incredible things you've done.
But just as a background.
You're running Illuminate Ventures
that I think you've deployed over
a hundred million dollars,
and incredible investments,
which I'd love to hear a little bit
about your investment strategy there.
Fast Company has cited you as one
of the most influential women in tech.
San Francisco Business Times,
something similar.
You're very excited about
women in tech in general.
And you have been a widely cited paper called
High Performance Entrepreneurs:
Women In High-Tech.
Okay, I've done my part.
Cindy, talk to me a little bit
about where you come from.
How did you get started with entrepreneurship?
And let's roll into illuminate ventures.
Okay, love to.
But your first question is a good one.
Because I come from a very
entrepreneurial family.
My grandfather left Eastern Europe.
Built his own business in the United States.
That was then run by my father and uncle.
Then by my four siblings.
Wow.
And now by the fourth generation
that's involved in that business.
So I grew up in that business.
I grew up understanding what it meant
to have integrity.
I understood what hard work was.
I understood what working on weekends meant.
Because I would go into the office
with my father doing
everything known to mankind.
And so, interestingly enough,
I assume from day one that I would do
something entrepreneurial in my life.
But I took an interesting,
circuitous path to get there.
I had to get my MBA at Carnegie Mellon.
I came out of there and actually joined
the largest corporation in the world.
At the time.
And I started really, really big.
And I learned what it was like to sell
into large enterprises
and all the rest of that.
But my first job was actually
a sales position.
Wow.
And I think that's one
of the best jobs you can have.
Including after you get your MBA.
Because you learn about
how to overcome obstacles.
[--]
Cindy,  I'm sorry.
I'm losing you a little bit.
I'm sorry I lost you.
Can you go back to that?
About why the sales is,
Why having a sales position
early on is important?
Yeah.
I think it's really interesting
about having an early role
in your life in sales is that
you are constantly facing
obstacles and objections.
And you learn how to overcome those.
You learn how to deal with adversity.
You learn how to deal when people say no.
And to move on.
And continue feeling that you can still
be successful in spite of one person,
perhaps one customer saying "No".
I think those are skills and learnings
that are really, really helpful as an entrepreneur.
I've heard that quite a few times,
I've heard it quite a few times actually.
That  one of the most important things
to really hone in is,
especially as young entrepreneurs
is to be able to sell.
Which is or almost
counter intuitive to what you know,
I grew up learning is selling is bad.
Just build impactful stuff
and and the people will come to you.
But now I hear a lot of really
incredible people say that
actually having the skill sets
of selling and being able
to communicate well,
that's incredibly important.
Yeah, I think sales is a really
maligned job and title.
In some companies, I remember
when I was doing this at IBM
you were they were pull up marketers.
And I think this is not marketing.
They're selling.
You know, just face it.
Admit it. Be proud of it.
And I was proud of it.
I was one of the top 10 sales people
in an organization that
had hundreds of thousands of employees.
You were one of the
top 10 salespeople at IBM?
At AT&T.
Yeah.
Wow. Unbelievable.
And I was very proud of that. Right?
And you had to work very hard to get that.
But it wasn't that
I wanted to be a salesperson.
The rest of my life.
But what a great experience.
I mean, even after my MBA,
the training they put me through
included how to overcome objections.
How to communicate better with people.
Helped me understand my own style.
And how that could relate to other people.
And it was super helpful.
And it also took me down
a notch or two from time to time
when customers just said "No".
Right. Well, I'm guessing that
to get to the top,
then you have a lot of yeses
along with those no's.
So, I'm guessing that
that's pretty incredible.
So, take me to Illuminate Ventures.
And why are you running a venture firm?
Why are you investing in other entrepreneurs
having gone through your path?
That's a great question as well.
I had gotten to a point in my career
where I had been, I've been
at a number of startups.
I had founded my own.
We had been fortunate to have that
be acquired by a public company.
And I started working with some
of my friends in the venture community.
Doing roles that people today
would call venture partner.
Operating partner kinds of activities.
And I had an amazing opportunity to work
with some very respected investors.
I didn't start doing that thinking
I would become a VC.
But over time, I realized that
it was an amazing opportunity for me
to start applying skills and experiences.
And just knowledge sets that
I had acquired over many many years.
And my network.
And I would say the network itself
was perhaps the most important element of it.
I knew investors because I had been out
raising capital for my own company.
I knew entrepreneurs because I'd been
in several entrepreneurial startups.
And I also knew people in the corporate world,
customers, business partners, etcetera
that I could then leverage
those relationships to help
a whole series of founders.
Rather than just help myself
getting access into those.
And I suddenly started discovering
that even though I had never set out to do it,
I didn't have a finance degree.
I had a very quantitative MBA
from Carnegie Mellon.
But I've never been
on that side of the equation.
I believe you very recently gave
a commencement address. Right?
To the School of Engineering?
The master's program
on the West Coast campus.
Yes. I had a really great privilege
and terrifying to do that.
Because you're always right.
Oh no. You don't want to mess up
someone's college graduation.
There you go. Yeah.
It was a great honor. Yes.
But in any case,
the opportunity for me suddenly
just staring me right in the face.
So, I looked at it and I said,
"Why not create a portfolio versus invest
all of my time and energy in one company?
And why not start giving
back into my community  of the things
that I've learned over so many years
and experiences."
And then I had the good fortune to be
invited to join one of those firms
that I was doing some projects with.
I invested out of their fund
for about four years.
Had an opportunity to build
a track record of it.
Then 2008 came along.
And that was super interesting.
Because the firm I was with have
had offered me a full partnership.
They were going to go out
and raise a new fund.
But I stood back and I realized
how much the world had changed.
When I started my company,
a company called Vivant,
which was a SAS services
procurement software company.
The public cloud didn't yet exist.
And so we had to--
When was this again?
That was in 1999.
Wow. So the Internet is about
four or five years old, really. Right?
That's right. No, no, no.
Pre-AWS. That's for sure. Right?
And yet there were companies that were
choosing to move down the path of
having a recurring revenue model
of building a multi-tenant architecture.
But we had to spend a lot of money to do that.
We had to buy all of those tools anyway.
We had to spend
hundreds of thousands of dollars
for an Oracle database slice sets
with all sorts of servers.
And then we had to pay
to host everything at Rackspace.
So we created our own.
And that's what every company
them that wanted to do what  SAS had to do.
And then, of course,
brilliant people came after that.
And that's what I stood back and realized,
"My gosh, I needed $2 million
just to start my company."
I needed to buy the servers
of the software and everything else.
Look for the brightest  in the line of code.
And from 2004 to 2008,
I was investing in early stage companies.
But that was still series A.
That wasn't seed.
There was no such word as a series seed back then.
You had angels. And then you had series A.
And I looked at it and I said,
"This is just crazy."
Companies don't need $2 million.
Or $4 million to get started any more.
They need credit card.
And they need some chutzpah.
And they need to go out there.
And start building something.
I love it.
And so that's what I started looking for.
And I realized that there weren't any
seed stage funds that were focused
exclusively on enterprise software.
Most of the people starting funds
that were at that point,
they were called micro VCs.
Most of those funds
were focused on consumer Internet.
Because the people came out of their wall
or came out of some,
more consumer centric kind of a business.
So crazy beans were taken.
Many of them
I must have dosed myself heavily
because in 2009,
right in the middle of the financial crisis,
I decided to launch Illuminate.
To focus on exclusively
seed stage enterprise investing.
So, the world was collapsing
and you're starting a new venture arm
to invest more money.
To spend more money.
Yeah. I love it.
I started the firm and
I launched it in 2009.
And I understood at the time I was
at least smart enough to understand
it wasn't a great time to go out
and raise capital.
So, I started warehousing investments
using my own capital.
And when I went to raise the first fund,
it was small.
It was a proof of concept fun.
And I basically contributed those
investments into that fund.
And they became what we now call
Spotlight Fund.
Which we did a one
and done and closed it in late 2011.
Then we closed our fund.
Roman numeral one in 2013.
and Roman numeral two in 2017.
I guess that was mid 2017.
We started investing from that fund.
And my partner Jennifer joined me
just about a year and a half ago now.
And we'll go raise our third fund. So,
Incredible. Okay.
So, Illuminate over these past,
I guess, 10, 11 years.
How have you noticed this venture arm transition?
As you're gaining more experience.
As you're seeing hundreds
or thousands of companies.
What kind of earned secrets
did you gain over these years?
What kind of secrets have I gave?
Earned secrets.
Stuff that only from experience
you could really gain.
Yeah. I think one of them is
to really spend your time finding
the people that you want to work with.
More so than the technologies
of the products or even the markets.
If I've learned one thing, it's that
early stage investing is all about the people.
Right.
All about the people.
And, of course, you know,
there needs to be product market fit
eventually and all of those other things.
But if you've got the right team,
and you have a much, much
higher probability of success.
Not only that though.
Some of the companies that I've worked with,
I've sat on the boards now at Bright Edge.
It's almost 11 years.
And exactly before we took them public
and then they were acquired by [--]
and that was 10 years.
And so, you really better,
at minimum,
trust and respect the people
that you're going to invest in.
Because you may be working with them,
if you're lucky, for a very long time.
That's the goal.
So, have you ever invested in a company
that you didn't necessarily believe in?
But you really believed in the people.
And you felt that these people are a good, bad.
Maybe the product is not.
But I trust that they'll pivot if necessary.
I don't think so. To be really honest.
Well, I think that in you're seeing
a thousand deals a year or something.
Then you're going to find a good combination.
Right?
But we have the opportunity to be very
selective and entrepreneurs do as well.
And, you know, we look for the fit.
You look for the fit. I love that.
Okay. Talk to me a little bit
about a women in tech.
Women entrepreneurs.
I mean, you started long before 2020.
When you know things are looking up.
Talk to me a little bit about this.
What you noticed over the past few decades
as you're in technology?
You know, I don't have the luxury
of living so long and knowing
and seeing these things progress.
I'm coming into a time in the workplace
where, you know, as far as I'm
concerned, everything is equal.
And every VC that I talk to
has at least one woman who is a
founding member or a managing director.
So, talk to me a little bit about
what's happened over these past years.
Well, sure, I'd be happy to.
So, when I wrote the first white paper,
which was back in 2010.
So, 10 years ago, it's kind of remarkable.
I was never intending to invest
only in women.
But, I did know having been a
woman founder, CEO of myself,
that there were challenges.
That there were some obstacles
that women faced and other
minority groups as well,
not just women.
That the typical white male did not.
And I thought it was important
to try and understand.
Are those obstacles
self-imposed in some cases?
Are they pipeline issues?
As many people always have suggested.
What are the obstacles?
And also try to understand.
Okay, for those women
who did receive funding,
who managed to somehow get to that level.
What happened?
How well did they perform?
Was there that the same level
of performance as men?
Or less or more.
But what did it look like?
So, while I was fundraising and doing
investments and everything else,
I decided to do some
research around all of this.
I ended up enlisting the help of two
master's students at Carnegie Mellon,
my alma matter, to work with me on it.
And I ended up reading, I think,
something in the range of
600 existing research reports.
Talking to the professors
that were doing the research on campuses
around the country.
Talking to VCs.
Talking to women who had founded
venture capital firms previously.
That had in most cases,
Frankly not been successful,
because they were funds
that focused exclusively on women.
And I was trying
to understand what happened.
What why didn't that work?
What was wrong with the strategies?
And I learned so much.
It was pretty overwhelming.
A lot of that is in that paper.
If anyone wants to find it,
they can go to our website and just go
to Illuminate Ventures or just
illuminate.com/whitepaper
That's a great domain, by the way.
But you know it was a labor of love
And one where after I did the research,
just to be honest,
I was never planning to write a white paper.
But I wanted the data for myself.
I put it into a PowerPoint.
I shared it with my advisory board
at one of our advisory meetings.
And they said,
"Well, you have to write white paper."
And I said,
"I don't write white papers."
And anyway, they insisted I finally did it
with some help from these students.
And we had a phenomenal reaction.
Because what we found
and what we discussed was
the really high performance
of women when they were funded.
And the fact that so many more than ever
in the past were qualified,
had the entrepreneurial skills,
had the entrepreneurial desire,
had the right training, education,
work experience, everything.
And yet many of them
not only were being funded,
but when they were it was
at a smaller level of funding
[--] table.
So, it was an interesting paper.
Then following that
just 18 months ago,
we published a new report
that focused more on gender differences
in existing entrepreneurs
and venture capitalists.
And we're right now finishing up
our latest in this series, I guess.
Now, and I guess I can call it a series
of unintentional white papers
that is focused on students.
And in particular on MBA students.
And how they think about
entrepreneurship and venture capital.
Fascinating. Fascinating.
And I mean. And really papers
are sort of considered a hallmark
of understanding the gender
differences in entrepreneurship
and in venture capital.
Cindy, you know, I'd love to get
your take on entrepreneurship right.
Before we started this talk,
you're starting to tell me how awesome it is
to be able to be a young
entrepreneur today.
You know, it makes me feel good
about me being a young entrepreneur.
So here's the reality.
It doesn't matter if you're young or old
from a chronological perspective,
but if you are thinking entrepreneurially,
if you are creative,
if you are innovative, if you dare
to take your ideas and put them
in front of other people
and risk rejection,
risk them saying no,
and gather that feedback and build
something meaningful from it.
I'm not sure there's any better feeling
that you can possibly have.
It could stretch if
it's just so rewarding.
It's such an exciting thing to be
able to be an entrepreneur.
So, before you mentioned the word chutzpah.
Which is quite possibly
my favorite word ever.
Talk to me a little bit about chutzpah.
What does that mean to you and why?
Why is that an integral part
of being an entrepreneur?
Yeah. So, some time ago,
someone asked me,
"What do you think is
the definition of an entrepreneur?"
And I said, "I think it's someone who's
able to look at insurmountable obstacles
and choose consciously,
knowingly to ignore them."
Not stupidly.
Not pretending they don't exist.
But choosing to ignore them.
That's chutzpah.
That's being able to have
the ability to put your concerns
and worries aside and
take the opportunity to put yourself
if you are, you're really
putting yourself out there.
Your ego is out there.
Because it's your idea.
It's your product.
And your energy that's going into it.
And then being a great leader,
a strong enough leader to convey that
to a whole team of people.
The best people you can find
that want to follow you
in meeting that ambition
and reaching that goal.
That's more than  that want.
That's leadership as well.
But it's the combination of those two.
I think that it can make
for a great entrepreneur.
100%. I keep hearing that it takes
somebody that crazy
to forego a good salary
as an engineer or something.
And decide to go and run after
a crazy idea that could possibly
make the world a better place
or change the world
or move the needle in some way.
But having to go through those obstacles
and more than just ignoring it.
But actually tackling them
and getting excited every day,
tackling them.
I often talk to my wonderful girlfriend
about how excited we are
that we have people telling us that
what we're doing is not going
to succeed or it's just not right.
And we get excited by this feeling that,
yes, we're going against the crowd,
we're going against what people are
telling us, because we innately believe
that what we're doing is right.
And that it's going to work.
And even if we fail, that's okay.
Because  just that excitement
and the energy we get all along
is just worth everything.
Cindy, what are you really passionate about?
Today, you wake up every day,
you look at companies, you're investing,
you're doing all sorts of things.
What what are you really excited about?
Oh, my gosh.
You know, I think that
I love the work that I do.
If it doesn't show, I don't know
how to explain it.
But I love the fact that we have
the opportunity to build
long term relationships with founders.
I mentioned two of the founders
and I sat on their boards for 10 years.
It's a remarkable opportunity
when I stood with the others
on the floor of the
New York Stock Exchange.
And my founders,
the original founders of Xactly.
Were up there on the balcony
and ringing the bell.
I started crying.
You know, I started crying
and somebody said to me,
"Well, is it the money?"
"No, for god-sake".
But it is definitely not that old.
You've seen them when they just had
a slide deck and an MVP, right?
Unbelievable. Unbelievable.
No, I'm excited and passionate about
a number of different things in life.
And in some of it is how our lives are
changing because of the crisis
that everyone is facing today.
The innovation that's coming out of that.
The heartfelt sympathy
that people are able to share
and express and help one another.
In times like this,
you see the best side of people.
Right.
And how they step up.
I just think that  work will change.
How we all work,
how we all learn is changing so rapidly.
Because of limitations being
and restrictions being placed
on how we can work together.
And I think the innovation that is going
to come out of this is going to be--
I can't wait. You bring so much optimism into it.
I love it.
Cindy, right before we go,
I want to thank you again for your time.
It's so generous of you.
You have so much going on.
And really, I really appreciate
you taking the time for this.
I need three words that you
would use to describe yourself.
And then I'm going to let you continue
running this awesome venture.
Wow. I would say entrepreneurial.
I would say I could use two words for this.
High integrity.
Okay.
And yeah, Passionate.
I love it.
Entrepreneurial,
High Integrity, and Passionate
Cindy, toda raba.
Thank you very much.
I didn't, I want to also talk about J-Ventures
that we're both a part of.
We didn't get to that.
But I look forward to learning with you
on our work through the fund.
And thank you for all the support.
And yeah, good luck with everything.
And I can't wait to see this optimism play
out in real life in the years to come.
Thank you so much, Michael.
Take care.
Bye bye.